hey Samuel leaves here and with my
beautiful wife Amanda and you know I
have had quite a few requests over the
last few weeks saying that they want to
see a real live property documentary so
I know I've been on TV and does stuff
like that and there's been a little bit
of Phillip at the fix hasn't it really
yeah so what we're thinking of doing is
putting together a real life documentary
of what it's like to be financially free
I mean we do a lot of training so
there's going to be all kinds of behind
the scenes stuff that no one normally
gets to see and also it's going to be
real life so if you'd like to see a real
life documentary of property investing
of our lives and also of all the things
that can go wrong when you do big events
and run big businesses and staff and
stuff like that if you'd like to see it
real a documentary comment below and
what should disable oh we want to see it
yeah just say yeah we want to see it and
I'm sure we can edit it together and on
hopefully if we do to the documentary it
will include this little person because
you're doing how many weeks
so anyway property investing training
building an empire and leaving a legacy
if you'd like just that kind of real
life documentary comment below and just
say we want to see it god bless